was ist das richtig ein abgelaufenes
stück vollkorntoast
ja es wirklich abgelaufen doch jetzt
kommt die frage aller fragen meine damen
und herren was hat dieses vollkorntoast
mit dem heutigen video zu tun
[Musik]
snowboarder schmeckt echt scheiße wir
spielen ein brett meine damen und herren
da geht es darum dass wir dieses das
hier sind wir ja ich kann das spiel
schon relativ gut ihr hört schon dass im
hintergrund liegen derzeit läuft das
heißt einfach dass du hier das ganze
acht du sorry becker ich weiß nicht was
wir genau machen müssen das ist jetzt
haben auch noch eine flasche
runtergeschmissen es geht irgendwie
darum dass wir dieses trost hier sind
und wir dürfen müssen wohl in wien ein
was passiert jetzt nein das ist die
genießbarkeit 8 und scheiße rettet dich
trost rettete ich gehe irgendwie
hochkommt so kommt bei der weiterfahrt
und hoch mit dir hoch was mache ich
jetzt als nächstes kann ich mich nicht
einmal so hoch dinge sind ja genauso
hierhin und jetzt halt dich fest mit www
was soll ich denn hier tun also jetzt
haben irgendwie noch andere ansicht hier
und ich kann das toast von unten sehen
quasi ich weiß nicht muss irgendwie nein
nein nein nein hallo wo bin ich fand das
ding irgendwie kamera drehen alter wo
bin ich denn überhaupt ich bin nicht tot
st das wusste ich auch schon vor diesem
spiel also
nochmal von vorne hier steckt immer noch
ein stück toast hinten im hals das hier
ist die toastscheiben die wir sind das
heißt wir können wir drücken und können
uns einfach mal hier auch kummer wir
sind zwei scheiben toast jetzt sogar
dann drücke ich jetzt mal cool wir gehen
ihm wieder vorne hin genau dann drücke
ich jetzt mal ne andere richtung wollte
ich nehme jetzt sind wir wieder am start
hier rüber genau jetzt sind wir hier
jetzt können wir wieder hierhin jetzt
drückend war jetzt können wir nämlich
mal hier drüber gehe ja da ist ja käse
story dear sind wir jetzt auf dem teller
wieso warum ist jetzt plötzlich die
lichter angegangen ich kann mich sogar
[Musik]
sammelt das toast gerade den tisch fiel
ein toast nein wir sind auf einem
skateboard wer kennt es nicht das
skateboardfahren des trost also kommt
nein nein
tost neid kommt wieder hochkommen
skateboard kommt halte ich fest halten
die fans kommen du kommst wie irgendwie
hoch com a drücken genau wieder hoch
wieder jetzt mit am etat mit es mit es
kommt kommen konnte ja das ist doch das
ist doch nicht war darum ist es zu god
verdammte scheiße schweren toast zu
steuern was siehst du auf meine drecks
mission hier gerade was und dass dafür
eine kerze hier denn nicht da nicht mehr
déi hei kerze hey ich bin luca und ich
würde echt ganz gern eigentlich auf dich
mal nein das ist stress mich nicht weh
und es drücken genau dann gehen wir hier
zur seite zu unterdrücken dann gehen wir
hier zur seite und jetzt halten wir uns
hiermit s und w drums es geht nämlich
nicht das heißt wir drücken wieder
angehen hier irgendwie euro 2000 jahre
später ist ein wundervolles spiel das
wir das ist doch nicht deine warum steht
da oben überhaupt die ganze zeit greifen
ich tue was ich kann alter was solche
dennoch alles das
jemand der entwickler von diesem spiel
zukunft wichtig also wenn ich die rechte
maustaste gedrückt halte kann ich mich
so ein bisschen umgucken wir sind also
in irgendeinem haus da vorne haben wir
die uhr es ist gerade zehn uhr abends
beziehungsweise irgendwie kurz nach 10
kurz nach 11 oder irgendwie so um den
dreh hier hinten haben wir gar nichts
was bedeutet diese kerze überhaupt
hey was soll ich jetzt genau tun ich
kann ja mal probieren mit cooler warum
hat grenzt sich so oben links steht dass
ich eine unendliche genießbarkeit gerade
habe also ich gebe dir mal auf dem boden
und bethesda smile direct 8 mio
risk weighted das heißt das toast bahnt
sich jetzt mal so ein bisschen den weg
hier durch die pampa ich weiß allerdings
nicht wo wir gerade ehrlich gesagt
hinwollen jha stw
red
mailand
ich brauche eigentlich eine gitarren
untermalung jule begleitet das ganze
jetzt mal hier auf der ukulele
with the great idea
and the world is watching you
danke danke das ist hier wirklich ein
wundervolles spielfreunde also es macht
unfassbar viel spaß man sieht eine menge
ich möchte die ganze umgebung hier
das ist klasse einfach von der grafik
gestaltung auch freue mich wirklich sehr
dass ich hier die chance habe dieses
spiel zu spielen es macht unfassbare
laune gerade das ist spannender als
jeder blockbuster hier sind auch so ein
paar grafikfehler auf jeden fall mit
drin
vielleicht sind ja auch extra verbaut
worden weil ich meine leute die so ein
spiel gemacht haben müssen wirklich die
sind professionelle profis ich versuche
jetzt mal hier vorne einfach irgendwie
das dings hier hoch zu gehen
die küche hat super geklappt ich weiß
nicht was ich jetzt irgendwie hier
machen soll ich könnte ja mal einen
hundenapf gehen wenn paar sekunden
später das ist ja das ist klasse beendet
das level wird mindestens 80%
genießbarkeit okay das habe ich verliere
nie deinen griff was was ich habe jetzt
mal einfach auf level neu starten
gedrückt ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich
hier irgendwie machen soll ich meine cd
irgendwo was was sich irgendwie
erreichen soll irgendwas was irgendwie
das ziel sein könnte
wir machen das ganze jetzt nochmal
komplett von vorne also wir klicken auf
küche das ist nämlich der story-modus
das erste level auf ihren brief bekommen
das ist werde tost genau das ist was
soll ich jetzt gott verdammt nochmal
hier tun die oben steht auch die ganze
zeit greifen aber ich wir nähern uns
erst mal wieder der komischen
unendlichkeit scheiße hier die habe ich
jetzt das heißt jetzt machen wir mal ein
bisschen stress hier also wege norwegen
runter nein flasche
also wir gehen erst mal runter hier
vorne und sind jetzt auf dem boden der
tatsachen angekommen was mache ich jetzt
die können ja mal diesen fußspuren so
ein bisschen hier nachgehen also über es
gehe ich jetzt mal hierhin genau halt
mich jetzt mal hier fest jetzt gehen wir
mal hier hoch jetzt habe ich mich mal
mit aaa fest jetzt gehen wir mal okay
dass ich kann klettern gehört war genau
jetzt hier am es festhalten jetzt können
wir hier
bemerkungen kommen kommen ja nein nein
kommt es kommt es kommt so zu schaffen
dass es dieses gottverdammte stoßt so
können wir die wurst mitnehmen also wir
legen uns einfach mal drauf haben wir
jetzt können wir die eier mitnehmen
das sieht doch richtig lecker aus leute
ich sehe da hinten einen toaster
sag mal bin ich eigentlich zu dumm ich
dachte ich mache so eine coole time labs
wie das jetzt irgendwie mit seiner
epische musik wie schafft in den toaster
zu kommen aber das geht nicht also safe
muss sich in den toaster mal was anderes
sehe ich irgendwie nie gerade nicht als
missionen aber ich bin einfach viel zu
scheiße ich drücke auf kuh und bewegt
mich hier vor dem tod da jetzt hänge ich
hier mit a drangehen nochmal ein
stückchen höher genau gehe hier um die
seite rom und jetzt will ich eigentlich
es drücken wollen
aber es geht nicht ok ok neue talk in
new york in kom kom kom kom kom kom kom
kommt es geht einfach nicht es geht
einfach nicht ich habe doch eine minute
ich hänge am toaster freunde so hoch
comcom bruder lasse mich nicht im stich
50 sekunden war noch das ist doch nicht
ein verdammter ernst alter kommen jetzt
lass dich einfach in den scheiß poster
hier fallen 37 sekunden noch das ist
nicht dein ernst warum bist du denn so
scheiße moment ist es nicht schon sogar
voll verbrannt hallo ich bin bereit
gekehrt was ist das für ein spiel
ich wollte diesen einem brettspiel
einfach mal eine chance geben weil ich
gesehen habe dass einige youtube
hochgeladen haben vor einigen jahren
ich weiß auch warum das der jetzt hat
niemand mehr das spiel ist einfach
komplette scheiße weil sie trotzdem
wollte dass dieser vor eventuell nochmal
einen zweiten teil hochladen dann
schreib mir gerne die kommentare wie ich
das erste level irgendwie schaffen soll
das gleiche wenn ich das video gefallen
hat und jetzt das was jetzt hier
das war's jetzt hier vom
hier können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus schenkungen jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]